the journey is truly the reward I may
not be who I want to be today but I know
I can be better tomorrow working towards
who that person is to
me that's a choice for me the wins and
the losses whether the games come and go
yes am I dedicated to my craft yes have
I made mistakes within the business of
my craft yes am I going to make mistakes
moving forward yes am I ever going to be
perfect no I'm joking I'm I'll never be
perfect but but like at the same time
I'm just aware that you have to have
laughter you have to have fun in this
you have to smile you you cannot you
cannot put too much pressure in yourself
because this One Life to Live